حسنًا ، لقد دعمنا jcpoa في عام 2015
بحذر ،
وجدنا الكثير من أوجه القصور في هذه
الاتفاقية ،
نعتقد أن اتفاقية شاملة جديدة
يجب القيام بها تشمل
أصحاب المصلحة الإقليميين الذين
يعالجون برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية في
إيران ويعالج تمويل الإرهاب ،
وهم  مهم للغاية
لذا فقط اشرح لي ما
الذي تريده المملكة العربية السعودية
بعد ذلك ، نريد شيئًا
يمنع إيران من تطوير
برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية الذي سيمنعها
من
تمويل ميليشياتها العسكرية
والقوات العميلة في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
ووقف أنشطتها.  في
المنطقة ، رأينا مسؤولين
حكوميين إيرانيين رفيعي المستوى
يأتون أساسًا ويبتزون
ويبتزون مجلس المحافظين الذين
سيتحدثون عن عدم امتثالهم لـ jcpoa
بأنهم سيزيدون تخصيب اليورانيوم
وأنهم سيزيدون
أجهزة الطرد المركزي هل تعتقد
أن هناك ما يكفي من الدعم في
الكونغرس
لضمان أن  المحادثات الجديدة
لها سرد أوسع
بكثير مما كانت عليه في الماضي ، وآمل بالتأكيد ، لذا فإن
هذا شيء يجب على المجتمع الدولي
ككل أن يأخذ على محمل الجد بالطبع
لدينا مخاطر أكبر لأننا
في المنطقة ولكن إيران أثبتت أنها كذلك.
غير جدير بالثقة إذا عدنا إلى
gcpoa لرفع العقوبات عن إيران ،
فقد رأينا هذه الأموال تذهب إلى ما
ذكرته سابقًا وهو اضطراب
في المنطقة لم نر الأموال
تذهب إلى ازدهار الشعب الإيراني
لم نر  الأموال تذهب
إلى تطوير إيران
هذه أمور هي غاية أه
أه
مقلقة وهي تمهد الطريق
لامتلاك سلاح نووي وهنا
يجب أن نتوقف ونقول
إلى متى نعطي إيران
فائدة الشك
إيران ترفض بشدة  أنها
ترفض بشدة أنها ستقترب من
بناء
قنبلة نووية
والتي تقول لها ما أرى أن
كل ما فعلوه تحت
الأرض يهدف إلى الحصول على سلاح نووي
ما هو دليلك على ذلك؟  تخصيب
اليورانيوم وتركيب أجهزة الطرد المركزي المتقدمة
كل هذه الأشياء التي لا
تتوافق مع gcpoa لديها واحد فقط
أو قد يظهر لنا أنهم
يحاولون الوصول إلى
الحصول على سلاح نووي وهذا
شيء خطير للغاية
لذا مع الاحترام لقد تجاوزوا بالفعل
كل  التفتيش من
قبل دائرة الرقابة الداخلية أعتقد أنه بعد
زيارة المدير العام لإيران كانت
هناك أسئلة لم يتم
الرد عليها بشكل صحيح أه كان هناك
أه لا يمكنني الخوض في التفاصيل ولكن
مما قيل علنًا هناك
بعض الأشياء التي  لا تزال
أه بدون إجابة ما هي ملاحظاتك من
واشنطن
في هذه المرحلة إلى أي
مدى تعتقد إدارة بايدن أنه من
المحتمل أن تنحني من أجل بدء هذه
المحادثات وتشغيلها مرة أخرى
تطالب طهران الولايات المتحدة برفع
نظام العقوبات ، هل تعتقد أن
هذا  الاحتمال
جيدًا على الجانب الآخر ، نرى أيضًا
الولايات المتحدة تطلب من إيران الامتثال
للعودة إلى امتثالها في
jcpoaf في  أمرهم بالجلوس على
الطاولة
التي يقال إن إيران ما زالت ترفض
الجلوس على الطاولة حتى قبل
أه العودة إلى الامتثال ،
أظهر الرئيس ترامب دعمًا ثابتًا
للمملكة أثناء وجوده في منصبه وقع
صفقة أسلحة كبيرة مع الرياض
لدعم الحرب في
اليمن وإه أشرفوا على
مقتل أه
أحد أكبر أعداء المملكة
اللواء
سولوموني إدارة بايدن بالمقابل أم
تريد إعادة تقويم
العلاقة بإصدار تقرير استخباراتي
يورط
الأمير محمد بن سلمان في
مقتل الصحفي جمال خاشقجي عام 2018
وقد قام علانية بذلك.  قال إنه يريد
إعادة تقويم العلاقات
مع السعودية ، لقد رأينا للتو سيرجي لافروف
في المملكة ، هل المملكة
مستعدة للابتعاد عن أمريكا في
حالة عدم اعتبار واشنطن أم
شريكًا قابلاً للحياة
للمضي قدمًا
بشكل جيد ، فالعلاقة بين المملكة
العربية السعودية والولايات المتحدة هي
علاقة تاريخية هي
علاقة
قائمة على المصالح المتوافقة في
المنطقة ور  إنه العالم ، فهذا شيء
لن يتغير من
قبل الإدارة وقد رأينا ذلك
في الماضي وأعتقد وآمل
أن تستمر هذه العلاقة لأن لدينا
أه
وزير خارجية روسيا
والمملكة العربية السعودية لدينا أيضًا خير
العلاقة مع روسيا ومع العديد من
الدول في العالم ،
ولكن هناك شيء واحد يجب
أن نكون واضحين جدًا بشأن
سيادة المملكة وقيادتها
هو خط أحمر لن
نفكر في مناقشة
أم ما إذا كان التقرير  كان خارجا أم لا
أن هذا شيء
أه نحن بخير ولكن هناك خط أحمر
ولن نفكر
في تجاوز ذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر بسيادتنا